Toss a coin to your new Witcher.
A major recasting has just rocked
fans of one of Netflix’s biggest
shows. Keep watching to find out
how fans are welcoming the new Geralt
with open arms… or, rather… aren’t.
"The Witcher" has been a firm fan favorite
since first hitting screens in December
2019. Following hot on the heels of
HBO's "Game of Thrones," the show has
a strong cult following among fantasy-drama
fans. The premiere season was a smash hit,
but "The Witcher" Season 2 proved gold for the
streaming platform. Per Variety, it clocked up
"462.5 million hours of view-time," placing it on
Netflix's "most-viewed TV shows of all time list."
Things have grown from there. "The
Witcher" Season 3 went the extra mile,
managing to wrap filming despite
tough times during COVID-19. Lead
actor Henry Cavill wrote on the
show's official Twitter account,
"What a season this has been! I just want
to thank you all for your determination and
dedication through a tough shoot. Hopefully,
you can all get some well-deserved rest."
Undoubtedly, one of the show's main
draws is Cavill, who provides both
eye candy and action thrills in
his role of Geralt of Rivia. So,
when the actor shocked fans by announcing on
his Instagram that he was exiting the show
and being replaced by Liam Hemsworth, the
reaction was less than ecstatic. In fact,
Cavill fans are hitting the eject button
on "The Witcher" after the recast news.
If anyone had any doubt about how "The Witcher"
fans really feel about Henry Cavill as Geralt,
they just need a quick glance at his
Instagram feed. Cavill wrote on his page,
"My journey as Geralt of Rivia has been
filled with both monsters and adventures,
and alas, I will be laying down my
medallion and my swords for Season
4. I pass the torch with reverence for
the time spent embodying Geralt and
enthusiasm to see Liam's take on this
most fascinating and nuanced of men."
Cavill finished by informing Hemsworth that
Geralt, quote, "has such a wonderful depth
to him" and advised the Aussie actor to
dig deep and enjoy playing the character.
Cue the outrage. One fan wrote on Instagram,
"And just like that, the show crashes and burns."
Another vowed,
"I loved your enthusiasm for this character
and how much the series (games and books).
I am pretty sure I won't watch the
witcher without you being a part of it."
They shared that they couldn't
imagine the show without Cavill.
One fan went so far as to say,
"This is the worst day of my life."
Another said they were (figuratively) hit in
the head by a ton of bricks after
reading his post. They concluded,
"Shaking head to clear it ... WTF just happened??"
There's no doubt that Cavill did a stellar
job of bringing the lead character of Andrzej
Sapkowski's beloved fantasy novels to life.
His replacement may not be the Man of Steel,
but Liam Hemsworth still has
some impressive acting chops.
Some of "The Witcher" fans were kinda,
almost, sort of welcoming to Hemsworth.
A dejected fan wrote to Cavill,
"I'm sure Liam will bring something to Geralt,
but this role was meant for you.... You
brought so much for the show in general.
Geralt will never be the same without
you.... We will miss you so much."
Ok, perhaps… not really… that welcoming.